John peretti is an investigative
journalist and broadcaster who's award
winning television series include the
men who might have spent the super rich
and us and trillium pound island.
He's written articles for the Guardian,
wired and the Huffington post and his
book done the secret deals that are
changing our world,
tells the story of the billion dollar
handshakes that never make the news by
revolutionizing everything we do.
What?
Welcome to our show.
Thank you.
Bless.
Bless you for inviting me.
We're really thrilled that you're here.
I'm just give you a quick understanding
of like what my motivation is at
university,
doing a course religion in global
politics,
Sal,
as universities,
really,
really enjoying it.
Getting an academic understanding of
things that are intuitively understood
for a little while now.
Like your field of expertise is often
submerged financial narrative that's
actually governing and dominate in our
world from an ecological perspective.
Uh,
a media can,
can you follow the money?
That's all you need to do that old
cliche,
but it's.
But it happens to be a cliche for a
reason,
which is if you follow the money and you
understand where the money's coming
from,
who's making the money,
what the economics underlying everything
we do from the coffee we buy to the job
we go to.
It's why we decided to buy that phone
over over another phone.
All of these things have economics of
their heart.
And so if you don't understand
economics,
you don't understand how the world
works.
What then should we understand about the
world is we're experiencing it now.
What are the,
who are the dominant economic players
that are determining what happens in the
lives of ordinary people?
Well,
I think we are.
I mean,
trump has thrown a kind of spanner in
the works and he's kind of,
you know,
I suppose what that represents as we
know,
is it represents of kind of dislocation
of the old,
the old status quo.
But that was because that wasn't
working.
And essentially what we've had over the
last 40 years,
and he's a kind of,
I suppose a symptom or public a creation
is,
is um,
what we call corporate capture,
which was,
I suppose that's the creeping end of
government elected government and the
rise of global corporations.
And we kind of know about that.
But I think what's really interesting
about that for me is that corporations
haven't done this.
I'm out of some kind of evil
machiavellian plot is just,
it's just been a kind of failure of
government to be able to,
to run the countries that they
supposedly run.
You have.
You have a world that I see is kind of
the,
the operates on two different levels.
You have horizontally and corporations
who operate across the globe.
So they don't have any,
they don't have any need to worry about
territorial boundaries.
Governments operate vertically.
They operate within the narrow
constraints of the geographical state of
which they operate.
The two just don't meet.
And I think as the world's become
increasingly globalized,
corporations have just got the whip hand
and essentially government has become a
kind of civil service for corporations.
So the nation state,
which is a relatively modern idea,
is already been made in empower terms
redundant because of the global power of
transnational corporations and the sort
of resurgence of an f,
no identity politics.
He's just sort of a response to that.
So who,
who are the corporation,
I think that that's not,
you know,
I think that's what's interesting about
that is that that's just the kind of
logic of the way economics has gone,
you know,
I mean if you look at,
if you look at Putin,
he's really,
he's not really the leader of Russia,
what?
He's the CEO of Russia Plc.
Trump is the ceo of a corporation called
the United States,
you know,
and so I think it's interesting that we
have business people in autocrats who
are increasingly coming to prominence
because there's a kind of almost
implicit realization that that's the way
the state has to be run.
So iT's not as sort of right kind of
thing.
It's just that that's the nature of the
way the world is going to mimic
corporate models because the corporate
model is now the dominant model.
They stay idea sort of redundant,
that make sense now and we know that,
but we Can't admit that bEcause
Otherwise democracy becomes a explicitly
a fast.
Absolutely.
And you had that under the,
under the cameron and under blair,
you had the first sort of intimations of
this where they started talking about
the John Lewis model or you know,
they'd start to say,
oh,
what if britain was run like John Lewis,
you know,
and then that sort of got the adverts.
Exactly.
And now it's become the google model.
So it's like,
how come you know,
how can I.
And I went to this conference where,
which was basically run by,
it was organized by big corporate,
big corporations and they asked me to go
and speak to them and I said,
well said,
have you not seen my documentaries?
You know why you're asking me to come
into something.
Well,
we were interested in what you had to
say and the way they were talking,
they were talking aboUt corporate tax
specifically about corporation tax and
the avoidance,
which is an issue in the air remains an
issue in the air.
They were sort of saying,
you know,
tax is such a redundant idea.
It'S such an inefficient way of
collecting money from us.
We don't want to pay it.
Governments don't know how to collect
it.
Why don't we run the nhs,
you know,
why don't we just do it directly?
and the sort of what was staggerIng was
the kind of the breadth of their
ambition.
They didn't see any limits on what they
should be doing.
Well,
we had professor David Harvey,
a marxist professor in here,
and he says that sort of stitched into
the ideology of capitalism,
which obviously I need to tell you,
but to reiterate for our listeners is
the idea of infinite limitless growth,
like marxist theory,
origin points out the floor,
that we've got limited resources.
So inevitably capitalism will have the
mast itself.
We're going to need a critical theory
that continually exposes the fallacy of
a model that as infinite growth.
But what happened was an amazing moment.
I mean,
when you look at disposal,
you know,
disposable consumerism and I mean,
you mean if you look at the way that the
planet is going in terms of limited
resources and what's ultimately going to
consumers and you just make things that
we throw away,
so stuff that we bought,
you know,
things that we buy cheaply.
So the rise of,
you know,
the whole rise of high street riser,
prime art,
tk maxx,
you know,
little,
all these,
these brands that basically produce
goods that we could buy cheaply.
When you look at that moment,
2000,
around about 2000 and chemo has the very
moment where global economies are
beginning to stagnate.
Wages are beginning to freeze.
What we'd had was 40 years of quote
unquote growth where prices rose,
but so did wages in tandem with it at
that moment.
suddenly what happens,
wages freeze.
people's living standards can no longer
increase.
So what do we do?
We make products that cost next to
nothing.
So people have the appearance of
improving living standards,
but products just getting cheaper and
cheaper.
And of course the price is paid by the
planet.
And so this is like,
these are kind of the economics,
underlying consumerism underlying where
we are right now,
who are the most powerful global
corporations,
well,
when we talk to be,
or it used to be the oil companies and
the mining companies and uh,
and the retail and so,
and food unilever.
So unilever,
monsanto,
nestlé,
coca cola,
those companies run through.
Those were the big ones.
Yeah.
And what's extraordinary,
um,
uh,
oxfam did an amazing graphic where
basically what they've done is taken the
600 or so biggest companies on the
planet and then they've drawn their
connections to the bigger company that
owns them.
Right?
So it's like,
is this extraordinary family tree which
ends up with literally five companies
running everything and you think that's,
you know,
that's like,
if you wanted to believe in conspiracy
theories,
well,
you know,
just look at the graphics.
So,
you know,
it's not,
you don't have to believe you conspiracy
theories to understand that very few
companies are in charge of everything.
But now in the last,
you know,
15 years,
what we've seen is the rise of the tech
companies.
Obviously,
you know google,
apple,
microsoft,
amazon,
these are the companies that now people
consider to be the most powerful
companies on the and are the most
powerful because of what they own for
the future.
They'll own data,
they own data,
they own everything.
Everything there is to know about all of
us,
so prospectively the most powerful it is
saying that the way that we evaluate
power is changing.
It's not necessarily now about capital.
It's about potential power because of
data.
Data is the new oil.
Data is the new oil because the set.
Why?
Well,
because it's the most precious commodity
on the planet because if you own data
that means you go to market specifically
to people you can control them and
you control their consumer.
Got russell brand's house and russell
brand's houses.
Heating is controlled by a phone which
collects all the data and then collects
all the data and what you buy collects
all the data and where you've been for
the last 48 hours.
They know absolutely everything or will
know absolutely everything there is to
know about you,
what you buy,
what you do,
what you liked,
what you disliked,
that that is power.
Because what I heard is that sort of
maybe the word I heard that the uber
furcation,
that people will know that the way you,
if once they know your habits and your
patterns,
then like that there could be a sliding
scale of,
oh,
you need a plumber,
do you will it's christmas eve.
That's a thousand pounds.
You could afford to pay it.
That you can have a kind of a flexible
capitalism that's responding to the
consumer and extracting as much as
possible.
What I suppose is,
so one of the things that you seem to
suggest early jack,
is that without some oppositional force,
the limitless growth of corporatism will
devour everything and we're already at a
point where it's devouring the planet
itself and the traditionally we would
imagine the opposing force to be
provided by the state,
but the state has now become essentially
the administrator for,
for corporate is so that that opposition
won't be variety.
What you've seen with,
you know,
and it's not the first person to say
this,
but you know,
when you see brexit and trump,
you see in a kind of sorts of
inarticulated response to the end of the
state,
you see people wanting to take power
back because they can sense an end,
but they don't,
you know.
Do you see what I mean?
There's a,
there's a sense in which the state has
lost its potency.
Yes.
Before we can articulate it,
we know it.
We know it's felt and people understand
it and so,
but I think.
I think what someone says,
w one entrepreneur said rather
chillingly and brilliantly to me,
he said,
what we do is we invent a problem and
then provide the solution.
And so that's really what a lot of these
products are about.
When you talk about data and you talk
about the plumber and so on,
what you really want to do is you want
to start giving people options that they
never knew they had what like.
So for instance,
you know,
if you watched this series,
you're going to like this series.
If you like that series,
you would want to go on this holiday.
If you want to go on that holiday,
you would like to buy this car.
If you want to buy this car,
you might like to go dating these 27
different women.
You know there's an endless endless tree
that can be opened up in terms of what
your consumer decisions will be off the
back of one consumer.
It's and it's like,
but you're trapped on a plateau of
consumerism continually.
You don't have another role in your
life.
Your role is to consume shopping is
everything because you know when George
Bush was asked after nine slash 11,
what could the public do after nine,
11 twin towers?
He said,
go shopping.
That's the solution.
Helping
wasn't a frivolous thing.
Grows shopping is actually what elon
musk solution is to the road,
to the automation.
He says that essentially the only thing
we can do productive to the economy is
spend money.
Consumerism is what it's all based upon.
Debt is absolutely at the heart of it,
so the.
So the increasing debt that we have goes
hand in hand with the need for us to
continue buying stuff.
And so what you'll come to elon musk has
said will be paid a universal wage for
doing,
for basically going shopping once robots
do everything,
robots will be taxed,
we'll get the money and then we'll go
down to prime arc.
And that's,
that is the future for humanity.
That george w dot bush moment,
it's curious coming as it did off the
back of a seismic event that,
that represented in so many ways,
perhaps some unseen,
a cultural clash that,
uh,
that he's,
a response to.
It was go shopping it,
it is the modern equivalent of saying,
pray,
go and pray because that,
that is our ideology.
That is when we talk about extremism in
the more obvious forms of religious
extremism,
we seem unaware that the dominant
extremist ideologies,
one where we are consumers and like you
said,
entering potentially into a time where
you are nothing but a consumer.
Absolutely.
And I think this I think was interesting
is when we moved to online shopping,
what's that gonna do to the cathedrals
of consumerism,
you know,
the shopping centers,
these places where we go to worship the
god of shopping because in a sense that
that replacement of god with shopping
has been with us for half a century.
It's kind of what we know and we're at
a.
We're shopping is a profound,
is a profound thing.
It's not only profound in terms of how
the economy operates,
it's also profound in terms of what it
does neurologically to us.
You know,
we talk glibly about shopping addiction,
retail therapy and so on,
but those feelings,
that endorphin rush,
you know,
that release of happiness that has to be
replicated,
that addiction and you know about this
stuff,
you know,
that addiction to that feeling has to be
replicated faster and faster and more
often and more often the shopping is at
the heart of who we are,
how we define ourselves in relation to
our neighbors and our friends.
It's absolutely everything.
It's the heart of capitalism.
Yes,
yes.
It's the way that we,
the way we see ourselves,
if we're not consuming,
we're not existing.
Now,
whilst I see the the economic analysis
that you're conducting is the.
It seems to me is the truest way of
understanding this problem.
It's valid,
it's demonstrable,
it's scientific.
You can go look,
this is where power is.
Look at how it's responding to look at
the decisions that are being made.
Look at this reality.
Look at these deals.
That's why you're living in this
reality.
That's the way that's a way of tracing
it to.
In terms of change,
it seems that we are very difficult to
implement change on an economic level
because there isn't by definition or all
of the power is held by people that want
to maintain these systems.
I think if you understand why they got
to the place it's in,
which was money,
you understand how money is perhaps the
only way that will get us out.
You know,
I spoke to peter teal who created paypal
rallies.
There's silicon valley billionaire.
He said,
the whole problem with the way we framed
global warming has been in terms of a
moral argument.
We've put we,
we,
we've said to the public,
this is bad,
people don't care.
Daniel condom and the behavioral
economists said,
there's an extraordinary moment.
Basically when the,
when a problem is too far away,
we don't deal with it.
When it's too close,
it's too late.
He said there's a window of opportunity
where something can be done and that's
literally where we are with earth right
now.
But you see the pizza go back to the
pizza.
What pizza tail was saying?
He said,
if there's money to be made from saving
earth that believe you me will have
clouds with avn logos on them.
We'll have cows with,
you know,
a monsanto logos on them.
You know,
if,
if that's what's required to sort the
earth out is to find a way of making
money from the salvation of the earth.
And that's the way forward.
Yes.
But that's slightly bleak view.
But another quote that recurs in this
program is,
it's easier to envisage the end of the
world than the identity is invisible to
the end of capitalism.
But this economically will come before
the other.
It seemingly,
um,
uh,
but you know,
I can't see how it can be amended
through economic means unless you sort
of started.
We uSe for a moment that touched on the,
there are sort of biochemical
imperatives to purchase and spending.
We're doing it because we get a feeling
inside our anatomy.
It within our consciousness for me that
the opposition can only change if people
start looking at reality in a very
different way.
That's what I think is being suggested.
The way that we intuitively understand
that nation state is ending or has
already defunct except for in a
superficial way.
Uh,
I think that we,
we also know that huge change is
required outside of the systems that we
currently live with him.
I'm
kind of a believer in,
in the economics myself.
I tend to think,
you know,
I interviewed thomas pickety and a kind
of an interesting guy,
the french economist in a wrote capital
and I said to him,
what,
you know,
this moment,
what's to be done.
And he saId,
well,
you know,
we corporations,
we could,
you know,
we could create a global tax system.
We could create.
We could retool the imf and turn them
into a force with teeth that could deal
with corporate,
and I said that you're basically like
asking for birds to go in.
That's not gonna happen.
And he said,
yeah,
the other thing is will we could have a
revolution?
And I said,
well,
in what way are we going to have a
revolution?
Because the revolution is that you look
at traditionally,
you look at the russian revolution,
you can look at the failed 68 attempted
to revolution.
What were they?
They were the.
They were on the on an economic rise
where you had a prosperous middle class
that was demanding more what we have
now,
and he said,
yeah,
but what you have now is a potentially
combustible force of a middle class who
are disenfranchised from what they
believe they're entitled to from the
last 40 years,
plus an huge underclass of people who
literally cannot exist,
and that together is a recipe for
revolution.
That's what pickets.
He was saying,
and I think you know what you do have.
What we do have in history is we have
the inevitability of change.
That's one thing for sure,
so whatever we feel is now the
catastrophe of the moment we're in that
is going to change what,
which way it's going to go,
who knows?
But things are becoming more dramatic.
The cycles are becoming more dramatic
and as Adam Curtis said in this film
hypernormalization,
we've normalized the catastrophe,
so a point where we accept that as part
of the cycle and so that's an
interesting thing.
Well,
we're talking more about revolution
towards the end of our conversation,
but I emphasize and highlight now the
nature of this catastrophe.
Can you explain to us what's happening
within agriculture that demonstrates the
severity of the problem
you shouldn't have asked me to.
I will tell you.
It's pretty extraordinary.
It's pretty extraordinary because the
other.
You shouldn't have asked me that because
I just don't want to tell people what's
what's going on.
I'm so bad.
I mean basically the who did a report
two years ago now,
the backdrop,
a lot of science that was being done
across the globe,
they'd put sort of put it in one place
and they basically analyzed a lake in
the of region of France,
which had been undisturbed for a
thousand years.
Really?
They looked at the sediment in that lake
and there was any kind of really
interesting experiment.
Bear with me on this.
what they found was the sediment had
been pretty much undisturbed up until
the industrial revolution.
Then obviously things had started to
change.
The nature of the sediment have changed
that.
Then what happened in the last 40 years
was that basically the nutrients had
completely depleted,
so as a result of intensive farming of
intensive farming,
not just to create wheat,
but also to create basically animals and
dairy.
For us to eat and consume.
We had leached the soil of all it's
nutrients resulting in the fact that we
have just 60.
They estimated 60 harvests left in the
planet.
Wow.
So that's sort of a sort of a food
armageddon
is approaching.
Yeah,
and it's kind of learn.
And again,
you know,
when you talk to people in silicon
valley,
they say,
you know,
we're,
we're across this stuff because it's an
opportunity and you say,
well in what way is an opportunity,
synthetic soil,
vertical farming off I'm off world
farming.
They're talking about the martian for
real.
Could we turn the moon into an
agricultural place?
Could we move all the heavy industry
into space?
That's what Jeff Bezos is plan is,
you know,
this is the stuff that they're dealing
with now.
You know,
10 years ago it was all tech.
It was all silicon valley was all about
going into going into the micro,
the details of how a phone works,
what can a phone deliver as a computer
now it's like looking out into space.
All a super macro and that's where the r
and d is.
When I think about my own life,
it's kind of evident that there is a
problem just from the way that I can
share my own is aware of these kinds of
arguments.
But like when I figured my domestic
waste,
I think,
oh god,
passion weekend thrown away.
This doesn't seem right.
That there is a detachment,
there is a lack of consciousness and I
can see how sort of this is a personal,
it's a personal problem,
one level and I think we feel hugely
disempowered.
You think,
oh,
I'll put that in the recycling.
I'll help.
maybe I shouldn't do some more
composting,
but you will in the face of these
forces,
it feels irrelevant.
The other thing that I'm learning,
it must've disjunct in terms of power
and what a theme that is between the
personal and the power.
The other thing I would get from what
you just said,
jack,
is that when they talk about,
you know,
oh,
we'll just,
you know,
colonize the moon or whatever it is this
week.
It makes me realize how detached the
powerful or from the lives of ordinary
people,
because you mentioned a moment ago that
the combustible revolutionary engine
will be a a middle class,
which like a lot of people feeling like
that.
The privilege that they're entitled to,
the resources and comfort they're
entitled to is being eroded and then a
giant on the class.
Now that on the class is as long ago,
been nominated as disposable wherever it
was in colonization,
slavery onwards,
perhaps even earlier than that,
that there's a huge percentage of the
population that we simply,
we do not care.
You are,
you are already machines.
And when we get better machines to
replace you,
you know,
if we can find a nice way of framing
genocide.
No,
that's,
you know,
the,
there's a brilliant,
um,
Paul Mason does a brilliant thing called
the car wash paradox and it's basically
what was,
what was the car wash?
The car wash in the 19 fifties was this
amazing shining new piece of technology
right here.
It was,
it was going to automate fluffy buds
would come out and clean your car and it
will all look amazing.
What's happened in the last five years,
car wash,
the last 10 years,
car washes,
I started closing down right there in
prime locations in the centers of cities
which can then be turned into luxury
flats.
All these automated machines have
disappeared.
And what has replaced them?
We're dead spaces on the outskirts of
town where you have immigrant labor or
cheap labor doing the job that machines
would they.
So you know,
one option,
you know,
the machines had been made redundant by
human beings.
The difference being that human beings
have absolutely no rights.
They can be sat there and then and the
and the whole thing can be taken down in
24 hours.
Right?
So that is one future that we might
have.
The machines might not replace every
one.
What might have is we might have this
incredible moment and what we see on the
news nightly as we say,
full employment employment's never been
higher and yet they say also wages are
stagnating.
How can this,
how these two things correlate the same
time?
Well would mean increase in part time
work because of gig economy because
people,
what you'll have is you'll have the
people at working for like delivery,
uber,
you know,
so basically with no know were very
limited rights such as we decided,
yeah,
it's a reversal of all of the things
that were fought for in the last name
tree.
But with no one working for any money so
that he knows that the other future that
we might have these,
these are,
these are very radical changes to the
structure of society and society that
kind of,
you know,
maybe we're doing is going back to.
We had to,
we had a period of stability from 1940,
roughly two,
19 the end of the nineties.
So what we're doing is going back to
that previous period,
a period of huge human instability,
you know,
we call that that class the precariat,
we're all part of the precariat brick
area instead of.
Yeah.
Instead of being a prototype area,
it's beyond that.
It's the ultimate precarious class.
The global class.
One of the themes that I've noticed over
the course of these podcasts is the way
that power functions is to,
as best as possible,
more to facilitate its ongoing survival.
Eg one slavery gets banned.
It's like,
oh,
what is the best?
It was the closest we can approximate
slavery without using that word.
Well,
you could pay people next to nothing.
And when you give a sort of like that
car wash example is like that.
And what concerns me when you use the
silicone valley tech entrepreneur,
new sovereignty of these great,
powerful corporations that now dominate
the globe,
is that in this sort of,
in their utopia,
the,
the problems of ordinary people are
irrelevant.
It doesn't mAtter that there is this
gray in more first underclass almost not
matter anymore.
Now almost a missed that are just
holding up reality.
Yeah.
You have a kind of so much state of
bliss which is kind of created by,
you know,
a mixture of,
pharmaceutical,
you know,
what you have is you have,
you have a mental health crisis in
britain,
you have an unprecedented level of
prescription drugs.
You know,
I interviewed A gp in blackpool,
which is the,
you know,
which is the depression capital of
britain.
And I sort of said,
you know,
what,
what did pharmaceutical drugs do here?
What do antidepressants do?
And she said,
well,
you could argue that they enable
poverty,
you know,
what do they do,
what do they do?
I said,
you know,
do they enable poverty?
And she said,
that's such a complex question,
but it could be,
it could be the case that,
you know,
essentially what are we doing?
Are we medicating people where they Can
endure otherwise unbearable conditions
and what is the consequence,
you know,
what,
what are the social and economic
consequences of that?
What are the consequences of obesity,
which has its correlation with
socioeconomic background,
you know,
what is the correlation with the
creation of cheap,
what we call disparaging a cheap white
goods,
the crash and the price of technology so
that people are aBsolutely addicted,
stuck to technology.
You know,
when essentially,
you know,
25 years ago that technology was even
beyond the,
beyond their economic bracket,
they weren't able to afford that stuff.
Now this is kind of these big questions
that I'm not saying I have the answers
to,
but these are the kinds of macro issues
that we should be tackling and not,
not kind of separating off,
you know,
fats over here and it's unconnected to
pop in.
Technology is unconnected to aspiration.
Everything is connected and you have to
understand that he's connected.
There's a mental health crisis,
but the mental health crisis is excel.
If a result of these,
of this economic paradigm,
that's incredible,
so it's creating people that for whom
life is unbearable and instead of going,
oh,
should we look at this economic model?
simply drug the people that
swing mental health and your and your
and your income.
I mean blackpool is the is one of the
most depressed cities in britain also
has some the.
There's a direct correlation between
obesity and britain being the most
overworked,
underpaid country.
I mean those two things are not,
not an accident,
but even beyond the income jack is that
the quality of life that people are
living is if you are meaningless and
your life is meaningless and you have no
value and you have no purpose and your
role in society is simply to consume
knowing that you consumed,
you are what you eat and what you eat a
disposable products and you are a
disposable product that that's getting
juice.
A huge existential crisis.
I see.
I have the image of like,
you know,
when you're dealing with a lawyer and
like all the evidence points to live
like in a minute,
it's causing a mental health crisis that
were just drug them.
It's causing an ecological crisis.
Don't worry,
we'll go to the moon.
It's like,
well,
why don't you deal with the actual thing
of what you can't run life because a
profit making machine because it's a
struggle.
I think I see dead dead right,
and I think there's a strong.
I think the struggle that people don't
realize they see capitalism as this
monolithic evil.
They don't.
They think,
oh,
there's these companies are trying to
screw everyone over.
Actually,
the reality is the real struggle now is
not between workers and bosses.
It's between ceos of companies who
genuinely want to bring about change.
There's poor.
There's a guy who runs unilever and he
said,
well,
I said,
what's your greatest achievement?
He says,
to get rid of the hedge fund managers to
get rid of short money,
short term profit motive within this
company.
We have to do something about global
warming.
When you speak to them,
they talked like they are occupied or
something.
They don't feel like they're the ceo of
a global corporation.
You know the and and the reason why is
because they know that government can't
do paris,
paris climate changes of failure.
Government can't do this stuff and it's
almost like they think no one else can
do it.
We've got the power we have to do so.
The struggle of the future will be
business versus business.
It'll be the business visions of people
like mark zuckerberg who basically said
essentially in that facebook thing that
he put up,
I am going to stand for president
because now he's seen that trump can do
his version versus trump's version.
That's what you'll have.
You'll have competing business visions
of what the future should.
Except all of these people without human
beings are nothing.
The results,
these ordinary people,
unless someone can bypass that lets
people say that the reason that you're
engaged in this economic game is so that
other people can benefit and facilitate
and the only way to change it is to
disengage from the economic gain and the
only way you're going to be able to do
that is by finding and alternative to
making yourself feel better unless.
And like for me,
this is where religion becomes
interesting because it's a model that
exists outside economics.
It was co opted by economics early.
Yeah.
Was it a surprise that religion is
fighting back when we look at religion
in various forms as being the last.
Basically there's no result,
isn't it?
It's no accident that Jihadism stands as
a kind of,
almost as a,
as a sort of caliphate black flag
alternative.
That doesn't have to be the onLy
But again,
rather like trump,
it's an inarticulated slightly
incohesive difficult to comprehend
version of an alternative
because fear,
like on an emotional level,
fear and desire of fact that they are
irrational.
You where people are being kept in an
irrational state,
uh,
to perpetuate.
Consuming so fear and desire is
basically what you're continually
feeling.
These are irrational state.
So irrational,
alternative,
seem attractive.
I like,
you know,
I think that trump was just deserts.
If you,
if you feed people that information
continually jingoism tell people that
nothing has any meaning,
eventually you will get this mba,
brexit at the same thing.
I feel that the conditions were created
for it.
Now there are the,
there are alternate alternate
narratives.
Even within this global context.
I'm very interested in the example of
China because they exist outside of our
story.
So can you tell us what this is?
China,
China.
You have the kind of,
we know we're not talking about the
different corporations and you have put
in running China,
uh,
Russia plc,
you've got,
you know,
trump like kind of failing chrysler of
the United States,
you know,
like some mid,
mid seventies corporation.
Then if you look at China,
china's quietly getting on with it.
And the interesting thing is they'd
squared the circle of democracy and you
know,
growth.
They've,
you know,
when you go to davos,
what you hear,
you know,
which is the meeting of the heads of
government,
every uBi annual meeting in Switzerland.
The endless debate is how does democracy
get in the way you know?
is democracy compatible with the future?
You know as though democracy is in
crisis,
there's endless discussion about
democracy being in crisis in China.
What happened in China,
they basically state tiananmen square
was the,
was a,
was a watershed because at that moment
it appeared as if democracy was going to
have to be the thing that the ruling
party gave away to the middle class.
No,
you don't need to do that.
What you need to do is you need to sell
them consumer goods.
You need to move them into being an
aspirant.
We're middle class,
like a western middle class.
You can buy off any demands for
democracy and so China squared that
circle,
how do we make consumer goods available
in China?
Used to be the workshop of the west so
you know you'd always have light light.
When I was a kid,
I have my made in China,
made in China.
On the thing no longer now made it now,
now it's china's turn to be like the
west was and to become this,
you know,
the largest market in the world and
essentially we produce or africa or
wherever,
India,
whoever decides to be come the workshop
for China produces cheap goods for
China.
China is the country that the planet now
pivots on.
China basically bailed out the United
States after the,
after the subprime crash.
So you know,
it's basically like a giant hsbc loan,
you know,
China is the bank and that's really
loud.
Yeah.
After that crash,
trying twice,
twice,
China is bailed out the us.
So that means America is in debt to
China when you're talking about these
secret deals that govern the world.
So that is,
that is happening on a net that is
happening at the level of suffering or
at least national states.
Right.
That's not always easy because because
what you've got is you've got China are
operating like a,
like a corporation.
So it's like your operation with a
board.
Yeah,
like a highly successful corporation.
But you know,
what's interesting is the chinese,
they have this last,
actually this year,
they launched obo,
which is their grand plan for the future
of the planet from bloody terrifying one
belt,
one road.
It's the recreation of the silk road,
which was basically trade route to the
wet,
the trade route that connects the
planet,
globalized the planet.
What they see is they see China creating
a new silk road,
but they're in charge.
They also see the unprecedented need for
a power in terms of,
you know,
the pollutant aspects of what's going to
happen with growth.
They see that being dealt with by not by
an unprecedented rise in,
in investment in global,
uh,
in,
in solar and wind power.
And so they also,
there's sort of a weird combination of
ultra frightening and ultra optimistic.
It's like you don't know which way,
you don't know which way they're going
to go and you don't quite know how to
read it.
It's kind of a combo of the two.
I have two questions.
One is how did they avoid them?
Ocracy Just fruit consumers.
And what did they do?
Just basically the end,
you know,
tiananmen square marked was,
it was a cataLyst in terms of our men
who was a major,
major plans on the street.
The man would have shopping bags in
front of a tank,
will never forget that guy.
Yeah,
but how did that,
like I said,
that people were demanding,
we want to be invite engaged in power
and spite.
Instead it was like,
no,
you can have,
but how do you actually do.
What does that actually mean?
I think because how do you do is you
create,
I mean,
in a way the,
the,
you know,
China has a very deep seated with a very
deep rooted belief in the states,
in loyalty to the state,
the individual and the state being as
one.
they come from this idea,
that doctrine of the mean,
which is an asian principle.
The,
you know,
essentially the,
any kind of dispute,
a dispute between you and I.
You're not right.
I'm not right.
But the solution lies in the middle,
in a place that neither you nor.
I have thoughts.
So it's a kind of,
it's the doctrine of the main is a,
is a kind of,
it's a,
it's a philosophy of how you deal with
problems,
how you deal with solutions.
We come from a kind of completely
different.
We come from the enlightenment,
from the idea of a discourse,
me putting my argument,
you put in your argument either your
right or I'm right,
so it's combatative,
you know,
which was the dialectic,
you know.
So we come from a completely different
place.
So there's a sort of a spirit functional
thing.
It's a fun.
It's a fundamentally part of what it is
to be chinese is this notion.
Yes.
And that would not have been,
that wouldn't have been underwritten by
ideas of statehood initially.
That would havE been sort of self and
otherness.
The original confusion.
Well the rice field being this really
important thing to riceville being a
sort of symbol of the state so that the
grains of rice,
I like the citizens,
they all part of the greater good of the
state and that you understand that your
places as part of the state.
Whereas we have,
we don't have,
don't have that notion for.
We have the notion that the hunter
gatherer or the,
you know,
we haven't
ritualistic.
Yeah,
and individualistic sense.
Yeah.
So China has sort of philosophical roots
that are gonna help them prevail that
because we,
because of our identity myths of
individualism stitched into them.
So like how bay still pretty.
Presumably it's a stratified society.
China,
they've sort of diverted from any idea
of sort of equality.
Yeah.
Well it's interesting isn't it?
Because you have,
you have already used,
you still have demands for rights,
you still have a middle class,
you still have,
you'll still.
The human beings will always demand what
human beings do bond.
And so I think the situation for China,
and I'm not an expert on China,
but you know,
if you get one in,
it'd be very interesting to hear what
they have to say about this,
but it seems to me that the future for
China lies in there.
They're very cleverly avoiding the
western route.
They don't wAnt to take the route that
the United States to.
They don't want to be the country.
That became a super power and then went
into decline.
And so,
and I think part of that key to that is
staying true to the philosophy and just
this year,
uh,
you know,
jumping has basically become a,
the ultimate.
He's,
he's given himself the highest accolade,
you know,
he's the new now.
So he's absolutely total total power
over the state.
He is the state
what he's trying his relationship with
corporations then like they have the
image that we have.
It's
fascinatinG.
It's really interesting because if you
look at how western corporations bend
themselves towards the chinese market
because what they see is they see the
biggest market on the world in the
world.
And so how do we,
how do we go into that market,
you know,
apple,
google that you see that they have their
own versions of all the tech brands that
we already have.
So to some degree do they need to,
do they need to even have our tech
brands,
they don't need to acres anymore.
Chinese have no sense of needing to
eight the west anymore,
you know,
they're doing their own thing in gene
in.
Um,
uh,
all the,
the gene editing that they're doing now,
the crispr benign stuff,
I don't know if you know about all that,
but it's basically they absolutely
leading the world,
you know,
so it's that,
that's,
there's no sense in which I think we
patronizingly looked at China was like,
you know,
how is it going to develop,
how is it going to leap progress?
Well,
it's just going to,
they just think about the world in a
different way from us.
I say it's not a,
a narrative that exists as a comparative
except from our perspective.
They have their own original,
the ideology that is distinct and
separate and now I'm no longer needs to
see itself in daily active discourse
with our western narrative.
And in fact,
according to their own natures and your
motif,
they have a self contained ideology
where the individual and the state can
have a harmonious relationship and this
is going to be hugely beneficial for
them going forward.
And the thing that you said a moment ago
about,
uh,
the combustible force of a growing
underclass and dissatisfied middleclass.
I'm very interested in gaging and
understanding these forces.
One thing that is interesting to me is
with the diesel,
with this sort of a sort of recent
attempt to reengage national identity,
that would be the examples we've
mentioned,
trump,
brexit,
it's stuff that's happening throughout
europe and it's a aids I'm distilling to
fail.
These ideas.
People marching in charlottesville
aren't going to get what they want.
People that will want to reimpose a
national identity,
they're not going to get what they want.
The sort of source satisfaction and pain
will continue and many of the examples
that you've given across this show of
like health crisis,
agricultural crisis,
they all point to the power of these
transnational corporations.
Now when people are saying what we want
is to condemn migrants,
they are simply another symptom of the
problem that you have diagnosed.
How do you think we can engage the
energy of the basically everybody in the
world.
How do you direct that?
How do you tell this story?
How?
What have you learned?
You know,
It's all.
I make these series and I try to analyze
and as objective as possible how things
work,
you know,
how the world works and what people say
to me every single time is what are the
solutions,
what's your solution to this,
what do we do?
And in a way that is enough that people
ask that question because we're at a
moment where we can't talk about
revolution in the 20th century way.
We can't talk about people going to the
barricades and deciding that they're
going to take over the post office or
something that isn't going to happen.
We're going,
we're going to a space where,
you know,
it's,
it's that thing that you mentioned
earlier about the supermicro and the
super macro.
It's kind of,
we laugh when we put stuff in our
recycling bin,
but you know,
I went to detroit and went to camden,
New Jersey,
which is the most poverty stricken
system was crime ridden city in America.
People are moving there because it's
super cheap.
It's like basically you've got people
starting up businesses like you know,
and you just think,
you know,
there's kind of something.
They're growing vegetables in their
front door.
There's something kind of laughable and
laudable and brilliant at the same time
about people just doing stuff for
themselves.
It's almost a kind of millennial
generational sort of reaction to this
idea that you've got to be on twitter
and facebook and whatever it is
endlessly,
you know,
it's a kind of almost like a progressive
luddite.
Autism or something,
you know?
Do you see what I mean?
You know,
the kind of techno prairie,
someone said,
oh,
you were on the techno prairie.
We're all got wifi,
but I'm growing carrots.
You know,
it's kind of like,
I think that's,
I think there's going to be 50 different
strains of rebellion against the system.
Whatever the hell the system is,
you know,
and I think it'll take the form of those
guys who have just bought one inch of
the trump wall.
You know,
today they've decided to buy a meter of
the ground where trump plans to build a
wall across Mexico and they've said
we're going to make it legally
impossible for him to do.
So that is a clever lateral way of
rebelling.
And I think that that's what human
beings are doing all the time.
You know,
I try to buy south the a kind of present
way.
I try to basically the,
the,
the franchise was up for southeastern
railways was most failing british
railway and the commuters have a
miserable time.
I said to the bbc and the communities,
why don't we try and run the railway
ourselves?
Why don't we bid for the franchise?
We put together a bit just from all the
people who are on the train.
You had expertise on the train of like
you had nurses,
care workers,
accountants,
every conceivable a hedge fund managers,
every conceivable person brought
together for the purposes of a common
good.
And the department of transport turned
it down just simply because we weren't.
They said we hadn't gone through the
right hoops,
but essentially we put together a
credible plan which was then taken on
board by them.
And you think that's kind of the future.
Thinking laterally,
thinking differently,
connecting with people in unexpected
ways and who the hell knows what will
happen?
Revolution,
I suppose is taking your power back is
saying,
I'm going to have my power.
I'm not going to defer it.
I'm not going to subscribe to other
peoples ideas and systems and whether it
is a growing vegetables on a tech now
prairie or to participate economically.
It's this sense that you have authority
and authorship of your own life.
Something you said earlier about the
cic.
I was themselves sort of wanting to
resolve these problems I find quite
inspiring because all of these systems
and ideas are built upon people and are
resourced by people and require people
in order to pop to perpetuate
themselves.
And what that makes me think,
jack is that the.
If you can buy what people are trying to
do,
like the ass end of this neck in
antidepressants,
in blackpool and in bad salty,
sugary food and buying crap disposable
goods.
They trying to feel good.
They're trying to feel happy and the
system that they are trying to process
these feelings through to no longer
provide for them.
So I,
I feel that what you said,
like the weather,
you know,
there'll be 50 different ways that the
important,
the,
the how is not important.
The thing that's important is that you
just start to,
that you started,
you know,
it's a very middle class.
I hate people in a way who are engaged
in politics because to me it's quite a
bourgeois kind of.
It's quite an,
it's quite an interesting thing that we
even think we have the luxury of sitting
here.
Like we are discussing these things.
Most people are just trying to survive
and you buy a bag of chips after having
done a 16 hour shift.
You don't give a toss about global
economics or corporations and sewing,
but you want one thing you want is what
you said is you want your life to be
better.
And it sorts of,
that's why you know,
changing your life and doing it at the
micro level is kind of revolutionary
because that's what matters to people.
That's actually what matters.
It seems abstract because in some
senses,
you know,
we live in infinite space,
but we also live in camden,
New Jersey.
The idea of infinite space or the globe
is all be abstract.
It's nice that we know it,
but the fact is we live in ourself.
We live in our community and we need to
have different relationships at that.
That's really community.
You see,
when,
uh,
when I was in the agenda,
the reason I had this sort of slightly
without sounding too weird,
I had to kind of epiphany moment where I
was sort of in the street and you've got
like drug dealers cavorting around on
like chilled children's bikes and
things.
It's just sofas in the middle of the
road.
It's just like the,
you know,
it's like a joke.
It's like the wire but for real and
you're sort of there.
And there was this guy and he was like,
he was busking and he was like on a
street corner and I had a lollipop.
It had broken up guitar,
which he put put tape on and he was
using the lollipop as a plectrum and I
thought,
no one's gonna.
No one's gonna give you like an
entrepreneur.
No one's going to give you money like
the most depressed place in the world.
He was giving it a go.
Do you know what I mean?
He was like giving a gun.
I thought,
my god,
it's like you walk down a street,
any street in britain or anywhere in the
world and you see 50 businesses,
some of which will fail,
some of which are and it's like all of
them.
Somebody had some crazy idea to start a
business and they've had a go and you
think there's something sort of
inspiring.
I think about the idea of people.
Then utilizing that spirit,
that human spirits to survive,
but then doing something together and
everyone who was in new in camden in New
Jersey said to me,
the reason we moved here is because of
community.
They said,
we feel connected to the other
businesses.
We are all together trying to make the
community work.
We're employing local people employed.
I spoke to the guy,
worked and worked and he said I would
100 percent be dead.
He was drug dealer,
drug dealer for 20 years.
He ended up getting a job for the first
time,
this place.
He said,
I would 100 percent be debt if these
2:19
year olds haven't come here and started
this print works and you think,
and he and they and they were only
hiring people from,
from,
from that side,
maybe rebuilding community.
What do we have in britain?
We have isolated,
isolated,
atomize people who don't know their
neighbors,
don't know anyone,
old people who live in solitary lives
and unconnected to anyone.
Building community is really at the
heart of what could happen.
We unthinkingly submit our ingenuity to
a preexisting system that has I hot,
not as you said earlier,
as a machiavellian intent,
but just as it's a.
I'm thinking emma,
our subjugation it.
So immediately you say our business is
gonna make money in order to.
And the other problem built in is that
we still try to use sort of state
solutions.
Well,
the state will prevent transnational
corporate.
Well,
we now know that can't happen except in
China,
but it has an entirely different
anthropological origin.
So it seems to me that what a lot,
because I.
This is the bloody thing that's all for
that that prevents me from being simply
a narcissist is the I deeply deeply care
that people are suffering in this way,
is something about it makes me very
unhappy and furiously angry.
I kind of believe it's possible for it
to change that.
Yeah,
you must do is you want to ask around,
make noise,
documentaries.
Would you put yourself ruled out buddy
grief when you could be shopping the
misses and your mother In law,
but this is.
We all care,
but it's just that everyone cares
because we human beings aren't.
We see a woman who run coca cola said to
me,
look,
I'm.
She said to me,
I am,
you know,
it's accused the company of creating
obesity and so on,
you know,
the high fructose corn syrup and all the
rest of it.
and she turned to me and she said,
yes,
we did all that.
We didn't know what we were going to do.
We didn't know that was going to be the
end result.
And then she turned to me.
She said,
I am a mother.
And I thought that was an interesting
thing to say because she was sort of
saying,
I am a human being.
Please be reminded,
I am human,
I understand the consequences of these
decisions.
And that is,
you kind of have to hope that that's,
you know,
interesting,
interesting.
Like remind yourself this because like
you know,
a minute ago you said that thing about
like,
you know,
sort of,
if you've found this 16 hour shift
scaffolding or whatever,
you probably are going to just have some
chips and not think about or listened
to.
The russell brand podcast they use is
what you should be doing for him to
actually making it for you.
If you're a scaffold the police or
anything like that,
you don't feel connected to sort of
abstract ideological ideas.
But the reality is like your primary
identity,
it will be able to see a of coke or a
scaffold that is that I'm a father,
I'm a brother,
I'm a mother,
I'm a sister,
a daughter.
So like I don't like know.
It's weird because we do these things
were supposed to be talking about brexit
or wherever.
And I think brexit don't impact my life
as much as some shit.
My daughter might have said this morning
or my dog,
we humans,
we're.
We live in human lives.
These are ideological things.
As long as they're not impeding on our
lives,
they should be kept in the abstract.
So.
And I think the only way to do that is
that,
gosh,
this is may seem somewhat bloody
reductive given who I'm talking to you,
but it's to somehow replicate the
communal unit.
But we would tend to,
if unimpeded by post agricultural
ideological forms that benefit elites
and inhabit and subjugate ordinary.
That connotes really spot on in the
sense often thing,
and it's kind of really weird,
but I often think about the kind of
freud in emotional underpinning of
capitalism.
You know how everything is really
emotion.
They really,
even these,
even like we're all sitting here,
gareth's not saying a word,
you're sitting over up,
but there's a kind of like,
it's a sort of dance.
Everything is a kind of really nuanced,
psychological dance.
I'm talking to you,
you're talking to me.
We're kind of getting on.
But he could have gone badly and it
could have been,
it could have like it could have rested
on one thing you said or something.
I did.
It's absolutely tiny tiny decisions that
can have massive implications.
You think if you applied that to
economics,
you applied that to the decisions that
corporations make whereby you appeal to
the humanity of people.
You deal with people on an emotional
level and I've seen this actually does
have an effect.
We kind of overplay the hard money side
and we underplay the weird emotional
psychological side
because both of those things are
resourced by the prime or the desire to
gain resources has a prime or engine.
Yeah.
Like it's almost like I feel that
philosophically is psychologically.
It's like,
excuse me,
that you want to navigate people to
their,
to their cradle and their deathbed
continually like you were born once and
you were going to die.
Now that's,
let's accept that basis and make
decisions from there.
Not continually in there,
but I'm the ceo and by wednesday we've
got a pie chart or whatever it is they
have now.
Is that like,
you know,
take these people that come up with
these ludicrous maxims and ideas and all
night,
so an opportunity that the,
the,
the earth's only got 60 harvest in it.
I go,
no,
you're going to die.
You cannot,
you know,
and that's why the reason that I am
interested in religion is not because of
the sort of a bizarre cultural artifacts
of the cruise as a result of its time of
origin or the ludicrous prejudice that
one flies.
No,
but because it's dealing with the
fundamental you're born,
you're going to die.
You've experienced things that seem to
be very similar from what other people
are experiencing.
Can we build systems on that basis and
because I suppose there are sort of
differences between.
It seems that what we require our
communities that are of a certain size
where the,
the individual members of that community
have power within that community.
The other communities are earnouts to be
run according to their own values.
And that the idea of that being on a
national level these days is finished
because it's too many people to do it.
So.
And the state no longer has the
legitimacy of being the thing that
defends us from the,
I don't know,
the barbarians,
whether those are corporate barbarians
or barbarians that are outside of our
sovereignty hundred per se.
It's like aristotle.
Lillian,
isn't it?
You're basically saying you're making an
argument for the greek polis,
for the,
for the city state a state that
aristotle said hat to have a defined
boundary in terms of its size,
number of inhabitants,
for it to work economically.
It could only work at this scale.
Any bigger.
It becomes corrupted,
it becomes destroyed.
You know?
It's kind of interesting,
isn't it?
How far have we come?
That is the argument I'm making.
It might be a bit even smaller than
eight because of a chimps can only
handle 75.
People say it's like an arab city.
Well,
under the skin is finally reached the
conclusion.
It's a city full of chimps scratching
themselves,
picking stuff out of each other's hair
and doing things that chimps do.
So your book a don,
the secret deals that are changing the
world is out now.
It is noW.
Now,
apparently.
Yeah.
I knew the paperbacks are in february,
but it's out now.
Get this book.
I'll be getting it and reading it.
Don't feel mad and weird and conflicted
that you're probably buying it from
amazon.
Simply accepts that this is the way the
world is now.
I say thank god for capitalism was what
would we be doing?
You'll be listening to this on your
iphone.
You'll be buy my book and jack's book
from amazon and hopefully they figure
just kind listlessly plugged in a carrot
in your front garden that actually the
seed was made by monsanto and it's
copyrighted.
You can't plan it there.
Oh god.
Night.
Now you're talking.
Keep stock at the right conversation.
Find a church that has an amazing.
Brilliant.
Thanks very much.
Thank you.
It's really good.
The show was sponsored of course by my
new book recovery,
which is available now.
You can order it on amazon.
Also,
come check me on my rebirth to
birmingham fifa december,
less the 6th of December,
brixton,
19th of December,
and if you liked this show,
subscribe to it and give it five stars
on whatever platform you're downloading
it from.
Thank you very much.
That was under the skin with russell
brand.